[Musik]
zur Einführung Professor aus
[Applaus]
bewusst
[Musik]
daraus folgt, dass die Eigenschaft, die
Person zu sein, sich von der Eigenschaft
, Organe zu sein, sogar von der
Eigenschaft unterscheidet  Menschliche Organe, hier geht es nicht um
Kontroversen, nicht mehr als um
Kleinigkeiten, dass das Eigentum das gleiche ist,
sie werden nicht sehr benutzt, absolut niemand
besitzt, aber das scheint mir richtiger zu
sein, wenn ich falsch
liege, wenn ich fast immer die Ansicht von niemand anderem sage
etwas, das der
Rectus den Charakteren gibt, also warte ich auf
sie, also haben die beiden Eigenschaften
unterschiedliche Ausdehnungen, sehr kleine Föten,
Selbstbewusstsein, sie haben alle 100 Pfund,
und es könnte Menschen geben, die
nicht einmal hochintelligente Weltraum-Aliens sind
[Musik]
[  Musik]
die Motorgröße von zwei Eigenschaften oder ein
inkompatibles Bild, so dass sie sagen, dass es
unmöglich ist, dass etwas sowohl eine Banane als auch eine
Geldbörse ist,
wenn ein menschliches Tier wir sein könnte,
das dieses menschliche Tier, das
eigentlich
thi wäre  s man wäre alle Dämonen auf dieser
Welt würden unzählige Menschen nicht
genug sein würde gelten, dass ich wie zwei
Menschen in meiner Haut wäre, wäre die tierische
Person, ich wäre eine Person
, außerdem wären die Wohnungen von allen,
sagen einige  dass es einen weit überlegenen
gibt, der dies falsch macht, und dass es eine zweite Sache gibt,
dass ein Tier kein Spielzeug bekommt, aber
die Bewegungen des Gebens des Tieres durchläuft,
erzeugt eine Ausgangssequenz,
faszinierende englische Sätze, einfaches Hin
und Her und so weiter, aber die Person ist
diese Person ein Tier  Eine Person akzeptiert eine
Art Immobiliengeschäfte, tatsächlich ist es
möglich
[Musik], dass
dies keine Person zu sein scheint
[Musik] zu
wissen, dass wir Menschen sind, ist eine
metaphysisch oberflächliche Tatsache darüber, dass
wir eine Person sind, die die gleiche Art von
metaphysischem Status hat  Das Sein ist
dienender Student. Ich brauche die
sehr wichtigen kritischen Prinzipien oder
Fragen zu unseren
Servicemitarbeitern nicht zu
leugnen  bei
versuchen wir zu erklären
[Musik]
jeder von uns ohne dich würde niemals
Unfall
[Musik]
ist seit Ewigkeiten anders
Marsianer Ich weiß nicht
und es gibt auch ihre Persistenzbedingungen
, die nur für welche Exposition gelten würden
Versuchstiere zu überdauern
, das ist vermutlich dasselbe wie das, was
zum Beispiel auch Tiere braucht, also teilen wir unsere
Bedingungen für das Fortbestehen mit Menschen.
Wenn es also um Identität im Laufe der Zeit geht,
gehen wir mit Hunden zusammen.
Ich denke, dieses Beispiel war die Art von
nett bescheidener Metaphysik, die ich liebe
Wir können also fragen, was
Menschen brauchen, um in der Zeit zu bestehen, aber nicht,
was Menschen im Allgemeinen brauchen
, denn das hängt nur davon ab, was für eine Person
Sie sind, also könnten Sie sagen,
dass es keine persönliche Identität im Laufe der Zeit
als solche gibt  bedeutet nur, dass
Sie einige Leute überraschen würden, also ist
es nicht überraschender, paradoxer
zu sagen, dass es keine
Suche nach Serveridentität als solche gibt,
jetzt ist es so, dass es verwirrend klingen könnte
Da der Ausdruck persönliche Identität
in verschiedenen Kontexten unterschiedliche Bedeutungen haben
kann, stellt dies eine gewisse Gefahr dar. Oft wird
persönlich bezeugt, dass man etwas
anderes bekommt als die Beharrlichkeit einer Person im
Laufe der Zeit, eine Art
Selbstidentifikation oder etwas, eine Art
psychologischer
Herr,
wenn auch zufällig so  Manchmal,
aber ich sagte, dass wir nicht grundlegend sind
oder nicht, hat diese grundlegende
Definition
[Musik]
das soll nur etwas sagen,
was sportlich ist, es ist im Grunde eine oberflächliche
Aussage, die sehr tief geht, also macht die
Kategorie Person vielleicht einen ganzen Joint,
aber das ist es nicht  sehr tief
ja,
also wird oft gesagt, dass es eine
grundlegende Art ist, aber ich habe eine
grundlegende Eigenschaft, dass die Dinge
ein sinnliches haben müssen, aber und es sind oft
genauere Bedingungen all
der Dinge
Abhängig, okay, so viel, um uns zu sagen, dass es
eine tiefgreifende Geste gegenüber Tieren sein
muss,
nehme ich an, dass es eine Benachrichtigung geben muss  Wir haben eine, die sie
fand, war nicht nur falsch, sondern irgendwie
wütend, es machte sie sehr wütend. Ich denke,
dass Menschen so eine totale
Frau nennen können. Sie sagte, dass Menschen als solche
ontologische nie haben müssen. Menschen sind
solche Handlungen, die es geben muss  eine
Art und Weise, wie sie zwischen Personsein und Personsein gekämpft hat
, wäre nicht wie
bedient zu werden, damit etwas eine Person wird,
muss etwas sein, damit etwas entsteht,
nicht nur, dass etwas erfordert, damit
etwas aufhört, eine Person zu sein,
muss verstorben sein
[  Musik]
[Musik]
das sind unsere Entschuldigungen, dass sie dachte,
es müsse eine tiefe Verbindung
zwischen Metaphysik geben, und wenn der Partner das
Eigentum hat, dass diese Dinge
mehr Dinge alle Menschen unterscheiden, dass es
auch metaphysische Denker haben muss, was das
beschmutzt  ahnt nie gut, dass
wir eine Person sind,
also habe ich das auf Schinken gefangen, ein Bäcker
stresst
jede Eigenschaft, die moralische Bedeutung hat,
war der Atlantik auf Teilung für mehr
Bedeutung,
okay, bevor  Das meiste von diesem Prinzip, das
[Musik]
Ich sehe keinen Ich sehe keinen
Grund zu der Annahme, dass es überhaupt eine tiefe
Verbindung zwischen Metaphysik
Ich erwarte das nicht zu sehen - die Energieverbindung
zwischen  Flugzeuge und ich weiß nicht
, ob es irgendwelche Verbindungen gibt,
aber ich denke, die Verbindungen sind zu dir,
und ich erwarte metaphysische Prinzipien
weg von normativen Prinzipien auf Karten.
Ich weiß nicht, warum das nur so ist, dass sie
einfach keinen Grund dafür sieht  Angenommen, das
macht es zu unserer separaten
[Musik]
, also muss das Bewusstsein eine
grundlegende, aber bewusste
Beharrlichkeit für alle
Dinge sein, die nur Dinge dieser Ruhe
sind. Wenn es also bewusst ist, sind sie rostige
dauerhafte Bedingungen für alles Bewusstsein
Wesen, einschließlich derer, die keine
Menschen sind, müssen
allen bewussten Wesen bewusst sein, aber sie können
zwei verschiedene Arten von Persistenzbedingungen haben
, okay, also müssen wir die gleichen
Persistenzbedingungen haben wie Hunde und
Kühe, Schweine, weil sie c sind  bewusst, aber
das bedeutet, dass es keine Beharrlichkeitsbedingungen gibt
, die für alles, was wir sind
, gelten, denn die, die verloren gegangen sind, gelten auch
für Dalton-Dinge
[Musik],
also habe ich vielleicht den Bleistift gut, vielleicht ist
das nicht nicht die Verbindung zwischen zwei
Türen  Aber nie wissen, hier ist ein
Einwand gegen die schwächere Art, falsch, die
Person, die wirklich unterstützend
sein
muss
natürlich, aber
es scheint sehr lebendig zu sein, daher folgt, dass kein
Organismus, was diese für den menschlichen Tourismus verantwortlich sein
kann, und selbstbewusst
[Musik]
nur wach liegt und sich fragt, warum
dies ein guter Schlaf sein musste. Ich denke, dies
trifft auf eine andere Art zu  und noch
heimtückischer, uns als
Jules zu sortieren, wenn ein menschliches Tier niemals
intelligent und selbstbewusst sein könnte, ist es schwer
, andere geistige Ehren zu sehen, wenn menschliche
Tiere einen geistigen Teil haben könnten,
außer dass sie es sein können  bewusst zum Beispiel
warum könnten sie nicht intelligent sein wenn
selbstbewusst es wert ist und wenn die
Menschen an Pakistan festhalten, niemand ist
[Musik]
[Musik
] materiell zu sein, das muss man nicht leugnen
Aber die Tränen meiner Mine sind
sogar ein
Mann, denn wenn irgendetwas Materielles,
denkst du möglicherweise, was wir sein sollten
[Musik]